doesn't the fact that CNN had Barry
Weiss on suggests that actually they
know that there's I mean it looks to me
like there's a full-blown backlash
underway against cancel culture and
that's just beginning and CNN having
Barry Weiss on as a way of saying hey we
know we took a hit over the Sanjay Gupta
thing and the Ivermectin thing with Joe
Rogan we're gonna have Barry Weiss on I
noticed the New York Times
um uh just recently gave a column to my
friend John McWhorter you know who's a
famous uh kind of liberal critic of woke
Politics as new because woke racism you
know and I kind of look at that and I go
that's the establishment responding to
this long-form podcasting alternative
journalism I mean you got your start in
alternative journalism I mean I was in
the 90s alternative journalism was hot
but it's almost like it's become we're
the intellectual Center of American
right you know life is now where you
don't kind of go I wanted I I watched a
really thoughtful segment no one says I
watched a really thoughtful segment on
CNN they say I listened to a really
thoughtful podcast with Tim cast or
Jordan Peterson or Joe Rogan I disagree
with you because after the Rogan Sanjay
Gupta thing CNN doubled down and tripled
down on those same exact Define [ __ ]
points Sanjay Gupta came on actively
rolled back what he had said on Rogan
when he was like they shouldn't have
said that he he went out with Don Lemon
Don Lemon said it is horse medicine he
goes you're right and he's like you're
right yeah yeah yeah it's a little bit
it's funny because of course though then
like then that's talked about and so I
don't I don't know that CNN doing that
helped its own credibility any I think
it probably undermined it do they have
any credibility is the question uh and I
think that Barry weisting was a hiccup
it was a glitch in The Matrix and
they're going to go back to their
regularly scheduled programming doubling
down tripling down on whatever the lie
that they need to sell the American
people on is I mean you might be right I
mean we have this debate because we um I
would always have this debate with my
colleagues over because you know we
would point out look people are becoming
more per nuclear I'm a big advocate of
nuclear power including for climate
change but not just for climate change
and I've been up against the vast
majority of environmentalists and
Boomers on this issue
and we have seen a huge change in
attitudes on nuclear over the last five
years ten years that's why I went on
Colbert for eight years ago he I've seen
just a massive change
and at the same time people will respond
to me and they'll go well but the Sierra
Club is still anti-nuclear and it's like
well yeah but those are like the last
guys that are going to change their mind
so I mean peace will never change their
mind yeah Green Piece is mine but you
wouldn't measure our success by being
like you wouldn't be like well there's
still a pope even while acknowledging
that Catholicism has significantly
declined as a religion in the Western
World over the last 500 years but there
is the issue that CNN could say
something and then YouTube will panic
and then Implement policy based on CNN's
lies that's very scary I don't know if
you guys have a view of it I was
censored by Facebook
um
last year and it was very upsetting it
wasn't that because when you read about
censorship in the past and also some of
my favorite Brazilian musicians were
censored you'd always be like that's so
those guys were badass can I say that
yeah those guys were those guys were
real heroes but when you're censored it
just feels terrible like you're just
angry and upset my friend John Stossel
just sued
um Facebook over this and you just feel
angry and like you know that was
defamation though yes he's doing over
here being fake news and it's an
interesting thing though because when
they say they censored me and when they
censored me and they say Michael
schellenberger said false things it did
feel defamatory to me I was like I said
true things and now you're saying I'm
saying false things yeah so yeah I mean
it's um what's disappointing is that you
I knew people at Facebook I know people
at Facebook and of course they were just
of zero help whatsoever you know and so
you just feel really alone and of course
you you're sort of ostracized and
there's no recourse there's no way of
course to even to even apologize there's
no way to even be there's no way to even
have a retribution in any any way shape
or form or even forgiveness you can
appeal to the same judge that sentenced
you then that's not an appeals process
that's right exactly so this is another
layer to it that's cruel and and evil in
so many ways because the rules are very
kind of generic they Implement them on
some people and not on others and then
when they do hit you they destroy your
livelihood if they destroy your
reputation they they create consequences
that could have almost everything taken
away from you not just your you know
Twitter page or Tick Tock page I mean
there are some people that can't have an
Uber can't have an Airbnb can't have a
bank account because of their political
ideas in this country and so what do you
do about out that yeah build
decentralized uh internet technology
where you can you can also appeal to a
jury like the Mind system if you get go
forward Bitcoin is an answer to the
financial uh situation what about social
media there's alternatives to social
media but again the big Tech monopolies
with the help of government control the
major highways they were able to build
their infrastructure with tax dollars
these are not private entities to have
connections to intelligence agencies
they have connections to governments
they work hand in hand they worked in
Tandem and there's an argument of direct
government intervention but I don't
believe that the same government that
created this problem will be solving
anytime soon I think it was what the
Democrats in California were sending
names to Twitter to ban yep oh sure I
mean but so like okay so I'm interested
in Glenn Greenwald a lot of people are
interested in Glenn Green Well it became
more interesting to me in recent years
um he's signed up for this new platform
Rumble Rumble um yeah I have um I watch
YouTube I'm 50 so I'm a lot older than
you guys and maybe I'm just too square
but like I sit down and watch YouTube
and I see you and I see Jordan Peterson
and I see Joe Rogan I don't see Glenn
Greenwald and then so what do I got to
do I got to go into my Smart TV and what
reprogram it to get Rumble I mean it was
a little bit like what was the
alternative to Twitter that was there
for like five minutes Tyler last year
parlor I mean and then they colluded to
destroy it yeah I mean so you kind of go
there's a problem because you know we
were all sold on these platforms for
their ease of use and the idea that you
would get to see I mean that's what's so
exciting about Twitter still is you
still get to argue with liberals and
conservatives so now what are we going
to do we're going to have a platform for
liberals and a platform for
conservatives and we're all right it's
already what it is you build up Twitter
Twitter is the the the people on Twitter
who are prominent are like center right
people who are like staunch conservative
have are have been purged or banned
people who are like the far right was
nuked a long time ago except for like
some specific individuals the far left
however can call for violence no problem
then you have the mainstream
establishment left can literally
advocate for violence tell people to be
violent advocate for people being thrown
into wood chippers like the Covington
kids no problem
and then you could tweet us a joke learn
to code and get banned so we see it's
basically Twitter is center right to far
left
and what that does is it shapes the view
of these journalists who think they're
centrists because they're in the middle
of that when in reality they're leftists
so what do you do about that we're
building out the fediverse right now are
you familiar with it no it's a Federated
network of networks basically so like
things like Mastodon but basically it's
a you it the way we're doing it is yeah
yeah it's a social media protocol so
you can create your own social media
platform where your content exists and
uh I'll use gab as an example you know
gab heard of it gab is like the first
one of the first alternatives to Twitter
because of the censorship they exist on
the fativerse in that you can use any
fetaverse app and follow Luke on gab so
Luke's username might be like Luke at
gap.com I don't know if Luke is on gab
or whatever but then I I could go on you
know super web and then say I'm gonna
follow lucap.com and see his posts from
a different website appearing on my feed
on this website so what happens is
there's no Central authority to ban Luke
okay but you have so you have like
almost a million Twitter followers yeah
you do I have I have um one tenth of
yours and so why would you want to go to
a platform where you and I would have
the same number of Twitter followers I
mean or the same number of followers
wouldn't you want to maintain your
status superiority on a new platform I
don't care about the followers but I'll
I think a lot of people do like I I
certainly like in terms of the social
credit system it already exists it's a
number of followers you have on Twitter
well no no no it doesn't depend because
the algorithm decides who sees what now
I tweeted a picture of a hairless rabbit
once did it was weird like you know I'll
put it this way the people that there's
there's a there's two there's there's
two different kinds of people who become
prominent you know I was talking to a
friend who does like day trading stuff
and I'm like there are people who just
want to be rich who will eventually
become rich because they want to be rich
but I think most people become rich do
it because there's a something you're
passionate about that they pursue which
leads them to being well off I agree
there are people who have Twitter
followers because they're genuinely
interesting smart people or they're you
know observed event so they can see
things for other people and they're good
follows for that reason and there are
people who try to manipulate and game
the system to try and gain followers and
are worried is my tweet getting enough
retweets or whatever
I don't care about any of that I don't I
tweet random jokes nonsense garbled
whatever because Twitter is just
hilarious and so uh but for a lot of
people their Twitter followers is really
important social capital for their work
I feel sorry for those people it's their
identity for many of them saying aside
your your views of those people that's a
re that's a material reality in the
sense that it's an economic reality for
people so I guess I'm raising it not to
sort of say is that good or bad but just
to say I think that's an obstacle to
wanting to migrate you know over to a
different social platform so we're we're
on these videos are on on
Odyssey they're on Rumble they're on
right yeah bit shoot yeah yeah
you start building it out you blast out
one post to the federal version it goes
to your mind's account and your library
account and anybody else that wants to
Federate so like it could blast out to
your Twitter and like you can kind of
centralize your own so funnel if if
self-centralized as the uh
this project
expands
you'll have more access to bigger
networks because you'll be hitting 50
instead of one
so
we use YouTube but I cut down the amount
of content I was producing on YouTube
substantially to try and focus on
building our own website so that we
could have a user base there
when uh we started doing the show we
were getting like a thousand viewers or
two thousand viewers and if I was the
kind of person who was like we're not
getting enough clicks then we probably
wouldn't be where we are I want to do
the show because I had fun doing the
show I wanted to do it I make YouTube
videos because I have fun making videos
I make podcasts because I have fun doing
it if I wanted to make money there's a
bunch of other stuff I could have done I
have friends who work for political
campaigns I'd make way more money you
know I used to work in non-profit
fundraising and all of a sudden I had
these people wanting to consult because
I was making so much money for a lot of
these companies and I hated doing it it
was awful just selling stuff and
tricking them and so I just stopped
doing it and then a period of things
happened occupy happens I start working
in this and I enjoy doing it so I keep
doing it when I was traveling around
filming breaking news events I don't
know sometimes you wouldn't get many
views or make much money but I was like
I wanted to be there doing something so
it's true there are a lot of people who
are driven by a desire for ego and
that's why you get the New York City
establishment media because these are
people who are like I'm a worthless as
human being but if I get hired by the
New York Times then people will think
I'm cool
there you go yeah I mean I just I think
there's that but there's just also a lot
of people like you know for like a lot
of people like Twitter is too complex
and Facebook is like about where a lot I
mean it's Facebook is where a lot of
people have arrived and it's hard to see
them it's older hiding apps using apps
it's true although yeah the young people
are on Tick Tock yeah although I even
see young people just reducing their
social media platforms to Instagram yep
Instagram
yeah you know and so I I the idea that
we're going to go and make that work
more complex for people and that they're
gonna we're gonna get Mass uptake of it
I'm skeptical you need to simplify it it
needs to be as easy to use or easier
than whatever's out there right now I I
I I disagree
um so we're gonna make a modular without
calling out any individual company I can
just tell you the the strategy used by
social media companies to become big is
so obvious and ridiculously easy
it's simple
what they've done again not naming any
individual company but more than one is
they'll create an app they'll advertise
it to high school kids they will then
give those high school kids fake
followers quickly and they will give
them fake likes and they will give them
fake comments and then all of a sudden
you have a new app called super web and
some kid shows up to a school and
they're like where do I follow you oh
dude I'm on super web and they're like
What's that you're not on super web I
already got 10 000 followers and they go
oh dude John's got ten thousand
followers and they all want to download
it because they all want followers too a
bunch of companies have done this some
people have admitted to doing things
like this I think it was Alexis Ohanian
who said that in the early days I've
read it it was him and Steve Huffman
pretending to be different people to
make it seem like the site had users
otherwise no one would want to be there
right bigger companies discovered this
and started convincing young people they
were they were having they had followers
and then all of a sudden what happens
like you mentioned having that follower
account matters to people
so if someone's on Twitter with 3 000
followers and then they download this
new super web app and within two weeks
they have ten thousand they abandon
Twitter switch to Super web because
that's where their core audiences so
they think all of a sudden now they're
not producing kind of other platforms
they talk to people where can I find you
oh I'm on super web I'm getting way more
views way more traffic that then drives
a mass Exodus because people think you
know fomo I'm gonna go to the other
platform a couple uh uh new apps have
used this strategy very very effectively
and I actually had this conversation
with
um with some political groups about
wanting to do an app like this this is
like seven years ago and
it's painfully obvious that how it works
so if you really want to play those
games and do that cheaters win thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this Channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time